that's for the Zuko's mother joke what
duck tell us what happened to Zuko's
mother
oh well it's an incredible adventure oh
hello little cock-block
that joke guys are too clever for
your own good goddammit and yes I
purposely freezed on that so that
everyone could think I was gonna hate
the first episode Legend of Korra uh but
I don't I like the first episode so
gotcha again that's for if you're gonna
do a fake out like that I can do a fake
out on you so there you go even though
you're probably not watching this but
all you guys are so wha let's talk about
this is the beginning of The Legend of
Korra V logs and uh yeah I am so glad I
did not that I stayed away from
everybody talking about the show and I
stayed away from comments and stuff like
that because man this is at all what I
expected this is like way outta left
field but I really like it for that I
like that it's something very different
and I'm I'm so happy they're doing that
it would have been so easy just to find
another little kid another world that's
exactly the same as before another evil
army like the fire and age of a and they
don't do that and I'm so happy about
that um you know even the age of the
character is like totally different I
mean it was she like she looks like
between 16 and 18 something like that
I'm not sure but uh and her character is
different and I yeah I was really
concerned too that there's going to be a
lot of oh so uh uh Katara is gonna join
us or Toph is gonna join us on this
adventure and looks mostly like if I'm
right it looks mostly like they got sort
of that out the way early more as a way
to segue into this show the sort of show
where we are and help people who might
be confused by the show understand a
little bit more so you have Katara as an
old woman in there you have talks
daughter you have Aang's son hanging
guitar obviously so um yeah so I like
that I like that there's a
a bit of a cross over there but it's not
like so far they doesn't seem dependent
on that which I like
um and what I also really like I like
that this world has obviously evolved it
has obviously gotten more
technologically advanced and so many
times you see that in whatever in movies
or shows where it supposed to be years
and years in the future and they're not
that advanced that especially when you
see just how quickly we're advancing its
technology booms pretty fast and I like
that they're acknowledging that I don't
know how to feel about the whole New
York thing it is obviously New York
right now I had you live pretty hard
when she looks over she looks out over
the bridge and then sees the statue of
Avatar II whatever I mean it's just
obviously the Statue of Liberty and I
just Nick heard a little bouncer like oh
come on so maybe that's because it's an
American city though and I look at sort
of all the nations it was obviously in
cultures it was taking from in a Last
Airbender and obviously it's grabbing
very obviously from these cultures and
now it's very hot very obviously
grabbing from our culture so I like I'm
cool with it
for the most part I would have liked to
have seen a little bit more of an
original design um which it's I mean
it's New York but it's changed a little
bit they just put like some Asian D
things out if I give that a few points
it's like that's it it's L New York uh
so I would like to see a little bit more
about the same time man the animation
holy smokes
everyone was tell me that the animation
really goes up like even greater from
from Last Airbender I was like wow no
animation was already pretty good it's
just like the minute you see the city I
just went wow like it just blows away
how incredible this animation is I mean
this looks like anything out of life
that that's anime is in Japan right now
I mean
what's wonderful the interesting thing
about is that avatar was very clearly a
again I kid show a family show we're
both kids and adults could watch it and
I don't want say head leaning towards
kids but there was definitely it was
trying to entertain them just as much as
the adults here it seems much more
towards the adults uh when I think about
how colorful last airbender was uh
compared to this this is not that
there's no color in this but it is
definitely more adult it I think there's
a sense that doesn't feel like it has to
be too bright and too colorful you you
don't have to ring the kids in for this
if anything is sort of seems more like
they're trying to hit the adults so
again I'll be curious to see sort of if
that keeps going through this I mean as
of now looks like they're primarily in
the city well and I like this set up I
like that like I said before it's not
another war it's not another uh whatever
fire nation coming to attack everything
I like that it's it's this Center that's
supposed to represent everything that's
great about the nations and sort of a it
looks like it's where all the big
decisions are made and stuff and it
seems very corrupt it seems out of
balance it seems very uh full of crime
and and people are not getting along and
I I like that I like when stories go
into what happens after happily ever
after and they do it pretty well so far
it's sort of the same thing I really
like that about about the dune series -
I actually I mean I liked the first dune
but after did the Children of Dune
series I mean that's where it's like
Holy Smoke know this is interesting
because we've seen the prophet stuff
we've seen all that but I mean now it's
like what happens after the Prophet
comes and everything is supposed to be
good because things are never gonna be
100% good there's always going to be
that struggle going on and that you
always strive to get that perfect
balance but it's never gonna be perfect
so what do you do to keep that balance
and I like that I like that they're
taking this route uh I like the fact
that
at Quora is obviously very cocky and
sort of a blowhard but it's not
unlikable obviously she's she's been
given this great ability to harness her
powers very early and as you sort of
noticed with a lot of people that are
given sort of physical advantages they
flaunt it they abuse it and it's always
sort of that fun journey to see if they
can get them to use it responsibly some
do some don't but it seems like the
character has a good heart which I like
um and she's leaning towards wanting to
do the same thing this could be fun if
they because you with those kind of
people especially ones that do have that
great power in them already but don't
necessarily understand the restraint and
the control and the responsibility it
can sort of go either way so I could
like to see that played with sort of
like what they were trying to do with
Anakin Skywalker in the prequels I like
to see them really play with that and
it'd be cool if they could actually get
it to a point where if she didn't know
which side to turn to and you didn't
know either uh I don't know if I gotta
go that route I don't fully know what
route they're gonna take which again I
like in the in the last airbender series
they have very clearly well we're gonna
go to the north pole or South Pole I
forget I'm sure you'll correct me yeah
you know what we're gonna fly there so
that if he can wear waterbending and
he's gonna learn everything to stop the
Fire Nation here the setups a little bit
more uh not quite as straightforward and
it looks like it's still sort of taking
time to get set up and that's cool I'm
totally fine with that
uh I like these characters I like that
polar bear-dog I like oh I don't know
his name but I'm not gonna try to guess
it um but the the son of Aang I'm just
calling that um you know I like that
character I like how sort of restraint
he is but he also sees the possibility
and yeah is so far it's it's a good
start and
curious to see where where it goes I
think in in some respects is hooked me a
little bit more than the than the last
airbenders first episode but then the
second episode where it's like you know
that's where it got me
um and I'll be honest I'm more
interested in this show mostly because a
the how good Last Airbender was and be
that it is sort of so vague and more
adult that I I'm saying if last
airbender didn't exist and I saw this
show I'd be like what are they doing
with this what I like that I can't I
can't quite get a grasp I yet I enjoyed
that I got love to put things in
categories and stuff and I like it's
like I can't do that yet with this show
so I really appreciate that they're
starting off in this way that's like hey
we're you'll have to see you know
instead of wear this or wear that it's
you gotta wait and see so yeah that's
about it guys I don't know how long I'm
gonna do these cuz it's only 12 episodes
but I'm gonna try and get it done before
the next season starts over here it's
pretty soon so uh yeah I'll just keep
reviewing them and hopefully you'll keep
watching them take care